[Musique]
1er janvier 1804 l'indépendance
haïtienne
c'est aussi une victoire culinaire grâce
au général des salines et son épouse
marie-claire bonheur les esclaves
enfin savourer la soupe jour on n'avait
pas le droit de déguster la couche donc
lorsqu'on en a fumé pendant son avenant
nous on fait un saut avec ça vraiment
pour célébrer ce qui n'était pas à nous
mais maintenant qu'il nous appartient
notre liberté notre histoire notre
culture depuis la soupe jo mousse est
beaucoup plus qu'un plat c'est devenu un
symbole dans le patrimoine culinaire
haïtiens comme nous le rappelle l'insee
brunch est et grande gagnante de ce
concours culinaire vous êtes québécoise
vous êtes né c'est tout et c'est tout
plat quand même cette importance là
personnellement parce que dans toutes
les maisons à effet du monde le 1er
janvier c'est sûr que tu manges la sueur
c'est une tradition on se commémore ses
délices et en plus c'est délicieux
l'ingrédient de base de cette soupe
c'est cette courge qu'on appelle giroud
mans gyromancer une sorte de cause cette
espèce là que nous trouvons en haïti
puis à part ça c'est vraiment l'âme de
cette souplesse et elle ressemble à quoi
elle goûte quoi cette courge non elle
est très sucré
la pâte est très orangé la courge iron
man ou turban d'aladdin est plutôt
difficile à trouver ici
à défaut de ne pas le trouver on utilise
d'autres rouge qu'on trouve ici sur dow
après l'halloween il ya plusieurs sortes
de gauche dont on peut s'arranger avec
d'autres sortes de gauche
pour nos papilles et nous pupilles
l'achète marie-france missiles as a
accepté de cuisiner cette soupe
traditionnelle voyez ma belle couleur
donc la soupe va revoir cette belle
couleur là c'est pas qu'ils ne sont pas
la courge là moi j'aime l'appeler la
soupe repas
il ya beaucoup de choses on met des
patates céleri carotte la courge
on a les navets poireaux on aussi du
jour mais on a aussi de la viande
donc on a la viande de boeuf bien sûr
pour donner du goût à notre bouillon
phare seulement avoir des eaux
la base c'est beaucoup d'amour de temps
et de petits secrets éléments magiques
article ou de girofle on les figues ou
bien dans le piment fort ou bien dans un
monde sous de poivrons c'est qu'on
puisse les récupérer à la fin
et puis le fameux bouquet garni donc
avec du thym et du persil pas si à
l'oreille con mais chez nous on ne
trouve pas souvent ici mais je le
remplaçant de la criante
finalement il y en a plus qu'un secret
dans votre bon la nature et le secret de
l'elysée c'est très important dans ces
années-là bien et qu'est ce qu'on veut
on utilise quelque chose qu'on appelle
les pis moi j'appelle affectueusement
l'assaisonnement
partez donc c'est passé la faire tourner
plus tard à la maison c'est vraiment
persie delà du thym de l'huile du piment
douala comme ceux-ci sel poivre
donc on mélange le tout et ça va nous
donner une nouvelle couleur comme ça on
en subit par chez nous on l'a sur toutes
les viandes avec la ligne c'est
traditionnel et
on continue à le faire je vous vois
préparer la soupe ce poing pleuvent et
fait le nom de 38 ans après paris je
vais réussir ma via un des éléments qui
aident à votre subaru un bon bout c'est
le bouillon la viande on le fait
bouillir avec des épices pour que ça
goûte déjà très bon qui fit le bouillon
en grande tenue ont fini plastique et
encore de la ligne placée pour le bout
ça c'est pour le groupe
vous allez laisser mijoter ce qu'on
mérite
ça prend une bonne heure
donc là la cogex bridge les passer au
mélangeur je vais émettre au million de
paires ajouté céleri carotte mon avait
le bon goût après avoir ajouté tous les
ingrédients je la laisse 15 20 minutes
encore ces prêts qu'en fait la soupe
qu'on l'a fait là dedans il faut
absolument s'en aux plus gros la vraie
façon de faire haïtienne c'est aussi
cette casserole et un accent core plus
grande que feu feu feu la nôtre et on a
faim grande quantité parce qu'elle
assume jour où elle se partage donc
absolument si vous envoler y en aura
toujours y en a toujours en plus et on
veut partager notre culture parce que
cette soupe là elle est délicieuse
ambiance les lieux je rajoute les pattes
on peut y aller avec des spaghettis des
vermicelles vermicelles eto'o mais on y
va où comme elle est aussi symbolique
est ce que toi on a la même recette
j'adore j'adore cette question et la
beauté dans l'assaut du roman c'est que
c'est une recette de plus de 200 ans et
elle n'a jamais jamais changé de
génération en génération
pour moi je la même somme que des gens
qui vont utiliser j'sais pas moi des
vermicelles millions us les flics mais
la soupe
elle est figée dans le temps c'est
vraiment la beauté c'est générationnel
élaboration et pour faire honneur à
cette soupe on sort notre plus belle
vaisselle et c'est parti pour le partage
faut bien choisir sa couche la musique
j'aime sans doute au noir et de vous
accueillir
c'est vraiment un plaisir de pouvoir
partager ma belle tradition avec vous
non seulement c'est symbolique pour
rappeler les dépanneurs ce qu'on a eu
mais c'est rassembleur c'est familial
c'est le partage
c'est tout ça pour nous en haïti le
partage ce n'est pas qu'en famille
seydoux s'ils ont leur nom à vous offrir
une petite sauce oui voilà les
[Musique]
le beurre du frigo et dur et froid
comment le ramollir pas besoin
d'attendre une éternité avec une râpe à
fromage râpé la quantité de beurre
désirer même s'il est directement sortie
du réfrigérateur ou du congélateur
vous obtiendrez à bord qui s'étend
facilement sur vos outils du matin
[Musique]